I'm not so worried about artificial
intelligence and I'll tell you why the
reason relates to this famous gentleman
Albert Einstein he said that somebody if
he was falling if he was in an elevator
and the cable broke God forbid and the
elevators start to fall that person
would experience no gravitational force
it's called the Einstein equivalence
principle he called that the happiest
thought of his life how do you expect an
uter or an Arctic
intelligence could interpret these two
phenomena Free Fall the visceral
human-centered experience of Free Fall A
and B have a happiest thought for me
that gives me great comfort because it
really is occurring in the human mind
the human brain another thing that is of
infinite complexity and possibly
forbidden to our understanding behind an
ignorance Horizon like the big bang how
can a computer experience a visceral
sensation if possible and how could it
ever associate happiness with it